it'll be a colorful last week before the
Easter break at the Parliament with the
visits from Palestine to Egypt and
Ukraine
welcome to the agenda it's a platform
between EU member states and their
Eastern European partner countries the
fifth session of the yeren s
parliamentary assembly kicks off on
Monday participating countries include
Ukraine Armenia Azerbaijan Georgia and
Moldova expect discussions across a wide
range of issues and foreign affairs
democracy and health what we put into
our bodies is important but more
important yet is knowing that what you
think you're eating is really in fact
what you are eating
two words horse meat scandal in its wake
voluntary labeling was introduced for
foods particularly for processed meat
but any piece from the Environment
Committee want to go a step further they
want mandatory labeling can their
political pressure work on the executive
follow the vote on Tuesday it causes
babies to be born with underdeveloped
brains health experts say that there is
no chance of a Zika virus could spread
to Europe but 7 isolated cases have been
reported in Spain after women returning
from Colombia were infected in a move to
preempt any future cases arising
especially as citizens travel over the
summer the European Commission has set
aside 10 million euros for research into
the disease but is that enough to deal
with the challenges the virus poses any
Peas are calling for a clearer strategy
from the executive and all vote to move
for resolution on Tuesday and there are
time for some news in brief yoga will be
our banks have continued to make
progress a public hearing with Danielle
Nui
the chair of the European Central Bank
supervisory board at the Economic and
Monetary Affairs Committee who will
present the second annual report on the
single supervisory mechanism for thanks
to Western Balkan countries on a
different level but on the same path the
Foreign Affairs Committee will vote on
the 2015 progress reports for the
potential membership of the EU for
Albania and Bosnia Herzegovina
in trying to get to Europe they leave
behind everything one of the most basic
needs on arrival is access to health
care for Refugees representatives of the
Commission will discuss provisions with
any piece from the Environment Committee
on Tuesday
and finally Tuesday will see state
visits from the Grand Mufti of Egypt and
the foreign minister of Palestine and
that's only half of the gender take care
and enjoy the week